-Now, Hillary, yesterday
was Super Tuesday.
And, now, you've been clea
that you're not --
You're not weighing in
on the primary. Is that right?
-Not endorsing anybody. No
-Okay, but luckily,
we thought of a way
that you can give us an inside
scoop on the candidates
without saying
so much as their name.
It's time for "Bag of Secrets.
Here we go.
-Oh!
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Bag of Secrets, yeah ♪♪
-Here's how it works.
In this bag,
I have the names
of all of the 2020 candidates,
from those still in the race
to those who have dropped out.
Okay?
-Uh-huh.
-You pick one, read the name
silently to yourself,
and then give us your thoughts
or a little secret
about that person
without telling us who you'r
talking about, and I won't look.
-Okay.
-At the end,
maybe I'll pick one person
and ask you to reveal
who's on that card.
-Okay. So, this person and I
were reprimanded
for giggling on the sofa
in the Oval Office.
[ Laughter ]
-What? Wow.
That's pretty cool.
Alright. Alright. Okay.
-Okay?
-Okay.
-Do another one?
-This is fun. Yeah.
Go for it.
-Okay.
-It's got to be -- Right?
-This person delivered
the state this person
represented -- represents
to Joe Biden on Super Tuesday.
-Okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay.
I think I know who that --
I know who she is?
-Mnh-mnh. No.
-No?
-No hints.
-Okay.
-This person is a terrific
public servant,
speaker,
dresser, dancer --
-Dancer?
-All-around, you know,
really good person.
-What?
What?
[ Laughter ]
All I'm thinking about
is "dancer."
[ Laughter ]
Wow. This is funny.
I'm not looking.
I'm not looking at anything.
This is great. Who is that
-This person...
-Okay.
-...is an incredibly
talented person.
-Ooh.
-Young but charismatic
and dynamic
and breaks barriers.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I think I --
I mean, gosh.
These are candidates who are -
[ Audience exclaiming ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to pick that one up
right now.
I'm like, "Wow."
Well, these are --
Wow. Who was -- What was -
[ Laughter ]
These are candidates --
These are all the candidates
including --
-People who were in,
people who still are in.
Yeah. And this is a --
-Including people
that are up for --
-Yeah, people
who are currently --
-Up for re-election,
as well, maybe?
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Alright, alright.
-Okay.
-I kind of saw that happening.
Okay, good.
-Okay, so, this person's
a good friend of mine,
campaigned with me in 2016
and took me to breakfast.
And this person had
a totally vegan breakfast.
-Really?
Wow. Is that it?
Is that all our secrets?
-Those are all our secrets
Yep.
-Wow. Alright, totally vegan
It's up to the vegan
or the dancer.
[ Laughter ]
I think you giggled
on the couch,
it has to be with Joe Biden.
I'm gonna say --
-Yeah, yeah. That is right
-That was right? That was him?
-Yeah, that's right.
-That was him? Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What were you --
What were you giggling at?
-Oh, we were -- We were in
a meeting with President Obama
And you've seen the pictur
where, you know, the president
usually sits
in one of the big --
in one of the big winged chairs.
And sometimes the Vice President
sits there.
Sometimes he sits on the couch
So, he was sitting
on the couch with me.
I don't know. He said somethin
that I thought was really funny,
so I started laughing,
and he started laughing.
And pretty soon,
we were giggling.
And so, like, the president'
looking at us like, "Okay.
[ Laughter ]
We do have some business
to talk about."
-You guys got in trouble?
-We got in trouble. Yeah.
-I love it.
It's always good to get in
a little bit of trouble.
I love you. Thank you so muc
for coming back to our show.
-Aww, I love it.
-That's all the time we have
for "Bag of Secrets." Hillar
Rodham Clinton, everybody.
All episodes of "Hillary" ar
available on Hulu this Friday!
Noah Schnapp joins us
after the break. Stick around.